[Musique]
une
on
il
je m'appelle catherine de la côte je
suis chef de cuisine du restaurant le
lancelot
hachiro bois dans le loiret j'ai eu la
chance de faire un étoilé michelin en
stage et ma première rencontre ce fut
vraiment ce moment de passer deux mois
dans cet établissement et comprendre ce
qui se passait avec des professionnels
où c'était très technique très strict
avec beaucoup de rigueur mais on
travaille et beau produit on avait du
résultat et on faisait plaisir au client
et j'ai été élevé dans une famille où ma
mère était souvent à la cuisine cuisine
est le gibier les bons produits pour
aller grossir braisé cette cuisson les
saveurs que s'en donnait le régal autour
d'une table pouvoir déguster ses
produits et je pense que c'est ça qui
m'a plu le qui m'a permis de faire ce
métier là pour réaliser ma recette j'ai
besoin de légumes oubliés
je vais les marines et les assaisonner
de l'orangé du citron vert pour la
saumure il me faut du sucre du gros sel
les baies roses du poivre et de l'aneth
pour la marinade bavaud de l'huile de
colza noix tier du safran du gâtinais
j'ai mélangé de l'huile de colza avec du
safran
je vais arroser le tout les zestes de
citron vert et pour finir l'assiette il
me faut une truite de méréville la
laisse en saumure 12h des écrevisses et
de l'armagnac
oh
alors à commencer par le panel
la rue tabaga la pomme de terre
vitelotte
petites carottes fanes
et on finit par lasser zone mans j'ai
remis dedans le jus de cuisson des
écrevisses flambé à l'armagnac man
dégustation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
une